how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival but how do
I get in our biggest challenge as a
society is that millions of people have
been taught what to think and hardly
anybody has been taught how to think and
so far too many things are taken on
trust and people get away with far too
much foreign and domestic policy and
generally in public discourse you can
say fantastically stupid things and get
away with it no it's not done our
political correctness is a two-edged
thing the political greatnesses is
popular and successful because a lot of
it's simply about being being kind to
people and having good manners and no
one's against that and also it's a very
complicated field in which the whole
argument about about diversity and
equality gets quite difficult if you go
into it so know what I fundamentally
blame it on is the destruction of state
education system in the 1960s you could
used to be able to tell before the House
of Lords was was flooded with cronies if
you went to the houses of parliament and
attended a debate in the House of
Commons where most of the people were
educated since the 1960s and then went
along the corridors of the House of
Lords where most of the people in
education before the nineteen sixties
you could see the difference instantly
and the way they form their sentences
and the levels of knowledge they
displayed and it was a very good
contrast that's gone now but it actually
does Illustrated there was a revolution
in education at that time and those who
lived before it are totally distinct
from those who came after it and it
wasn't just that the grammar schools
were destroyed the grammar schools kept
all the other schools including the
private schools honest and once they
were gone the standards of everybody
slip no I don't i long ago gave up
putting forward solutions to everything
I thought well I've written all these
books saying this is what has gone wrong
and by implication what you could do to
put it right and no one paid any
attention at all so I've now reached a
conclusion that we're all going to sing
giggling into the sea at some point in
the very near future and there's nothing
whatever
do about it except if you if you'll
really where I believe before it's too
late
I'm too old for me I just say I sleep I
was only making myself unhappy trying to
do something about it
and as soon as I stopped trying to do
anything about it it was a great weight
off my shoulders it's not my
responsibility anymore
actually saying that there is no such
thing as free speech because all
currencies exist within a particular
framework nothing we say exists in a
vacuum so I wondered whether that was
something you took umbrage with or with
you I just seems to be identical what
the purpose is of saying that what's he
saying that serves to persuade people
not to bother about threats to free
speech I'm not sure why he said it or
what his purpose was and there is
obviously there is free speech and there
are restrictions on speech and there
they're visible if not actually tangible
easily detectable and objectively can be
determined so just disagree with that
the freedom of speech is a freedom and
like all freedoms it comes with
responsibilities the fact that you're
free to say certain things say about the
Prophet Muhammad or whatever it might be
doesn't mean that you should necessarily
say them I think that people should be
free to say the things that Charlie
Hebdo said but I think Charlie Hebdo
shouldn't have said them because I think
it was just there was no point in doing
so and it it achieved absolutely nothing
of any use but but they're two different
things one is them believing that people
should be free to say things the other
once you are free knowing how to use
that freedom
that they're distinct but what does
happen a lot is that people will use
claims of being offended or insulted as
reasons for shutting down freedom of
speech and that's completely
illegitimate freedom of speech is is
limited only in my view by the the
jurisprudence around the First Amendment
of the US Constitution and therefore the
obvious cliche about not being able to
shout fire in a crowded theater about
about not be able to incite violence
these are the limits on freedom of
speech which a free society can accept
and tolerate but beyond that people
should be free to say what they like and
after that it's governed by morality I
think it's wonderful to live in a
society where it's still possible to
discuss things we haven't completely
given it our and every event of this
kind is a good deal better than not
having an event of this kind and should
be applauded and encouraged the problem
is that the number of people who are
interested in going to such things is
severely limited and the number of
people who can appreciate them is
severely limited not because the people
themselves were born unable to
appreciate them because so many people
simply are not being educated to the
level where they would appreciate that
sort of thing and I actually think that
it's been a real problem particularly in
my own area of work the media and there
are lots of other areas of the the
privileged parts of our society that we
have because we live ourselves quite
pleasant lives where we can have
reasonably civilized invades we've
neglected to do anything about making
sure that's available to as many people
as possible and and that's been the
great failure of our society to fail to
protect and encourage the wider
application of proper education and to
keep this privilege to ourselves the
more of it the better and there would be
more of it and people would buy more
books and buy and read more newspapers
and and go and see more players and good
films if the education system were
better so everybody should be in favor
of that
one of the things obviously that we do
is we try and bring together as broader
demographic as possible in terms of the
speakers so pairing up you know
politicians journalists with scientists
philosophers artists or so in terms of
from your own experience and the debates
that you'll have today how do you see
you know do you feel that that's an
important thing it's usually important
one of the most one of the most
enjoyable things any thinking person can
do is enter a debate with others on the
things that matter to him or her and I
don't think there's there's anything
both more educational or entertaining or
satisfying if it's done properly and
people stick to the the rules of facts
and logic there is one problem in a lot
of modern debate that people don't stick
to those rules and they have no idea
what they are having a having a brawl
with Philip Collins I love argument
Blair iets get your tickets for the
world's largest music and philosophy
festival how the light gets in dog